my name is Brian Clark I am the creator
of high fashion living comp we want to
be the place that you go whenever you
need anything about fashion lifestyle
travel some excited to have the
opportunity to bring a group open by
very close knit friends together for an
experience where they'll have some of
the best food curated by Allison some of
the best handcrafted drinks made by
Skyler I'm Allison Roman and I'm a food
writer and I'm also working on my first
cookbook I'm really looking forward to
working with Skyler because I know he's
gonna come with a total awesome menu of
like really kind of interesting bolder
flavors so the idea that I'm working
with somebody doing is really cool sort
of more experimental cocktails is really
interesting to me
my name is Skyler huntin I'm one of the
senior bartenders at Tiger mama in
Boston the interesting thing about being
able to put on a party for these super
exclusive VIP is it really allows us to
give them something that they haven't
seen before you're never gonna have it
anywhere else and you're only ever gonna
get it from us and it's only ever gonna
happen this once
[Music]
[Music]
so the general like vibe of the menu is
sort of creating food that you can eat
all night long
mix it together if you want like nothing
has to be served like super hot out of
the oven and so for the salmon it's sort
of this indulgent like you cover it in
olive oil which is a lot of olive oil
but it's slow cooks in the oven with a
bunch of citrus and chilies and it is
the best way to eat salmon I think when
I read down the menu you sent to me I
was like oh I got to do a cocktail that
has a little bit of spice in it to go
along with that and that's like my
aperitivo cocktail it's gonna be gin and
charreah which is a smoked ancho pepper
liqueur lime juice and then the
sweetening ingredient I'm using is like
an agave syrup and I wanna grill
habaneros and how a pea peppers and
blend that into the syrup
the garnish how I envisioned it is
taking a bell pepper to a mandolin and
kind of twisting those up into lovely
kind of red bell pepper knots over the
top of the cocktail and then around the
rim a little bit of salt flavors will be
like huge and start off the night with
like kind of a bang yeah I think it's
gonna be really great so tonight is all
about a meeting of the mind between
creatives so we have bloggers and
influencers people from the fashion
industry and people from the music
industry so tell me about your first
drink and why it's so important to set
the tone for tonight so the cocktail
that opens the party is definitely one
that's gonna set the tone for how the
whole nights gonna go so I chose things
that I wouldn't usually see in a
cocktail or on a cocktail menu things
that are a little bit assertive and
really really flavorful to start the
night off and from there we just move
into more and more interesting flavors
as the night evolves they're kind of a
conversation style over there right
even into the night Cheers
[Music]
this is my take on a tiki cocktail I
made some ingredients that I don't think
I'm going to be making again for a while
one of them was pistachio or Jean I also
did you come reduce this is a fried
spelt and roasted wild mushroom salad
and what this is is shown trowels and
oyster mushrooms and maitakes and that's
tossed with a little bit of crisped up
spell this party let me off of my leash
the idea of playing it safe just to
create mass appeal for a cocktail
doesn't necessarily need to be the route
that you take creativity for
creativity's sake pushes me in that
direction more and more I've been to a
lot of events and this was definitely
like a very unique and one-of-a-kind
experience it's very rare that you get a
group of individuals that are all at
least like really awesome creative
fields and towards the end of the night
you would have never guessed that none
of us knew each other before tonight
tonight I can just say it in one word
magic it was authentic the food was
amazing the drinks were incredible and
people had probably one of the best
times of their lives
[Music]
[Applause]
so I don't know about you but I think
that was a pretty successful party and
we end with a dance party on a rooftop
in Soho on a Friday night sounds like a
pretty and once-in-a-lifetime situation
it was a very exclusive entertaining
evening for us I would say yeah and if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more like it please subscribe to the GQ
channel
[Music]